we still don't have many of the results
from last night's primaries and we don't
yet have the results for carrie lake a
republican running in arizona but the
new thing now among republicans is you
just claim that there's fraud even
before the election has started and
that's exactly what carrie lake did this
video is from monday night
on monday night remember the united
states we vote on tuesday the election
was last night but on monday night von
hillyard from
msnbc confronted arizona gubernatorial
republican candidate carrie lake who is
a big trump brown-noser and suck-up
because she's already saying that there
is voter fraud
and see if you can find the list of
things she does here that expose her as
an obvious trump acolyte take a listen
you're ordering contending that there's
a regularity that there is fraud in this
election at what point does carrie lake
stop and say am i undermining american
faith in our elections
but you haven't even laid out any fraud
for a regulator
[Music]
but what fraud
i would tell them
all right so let's look at the list of
things that carrie lake did there that
exposed her as an obvious trumpus number
one she referred to herself in the third
person referring to herself as carrie
lake uh remember that trump would always
say they want trump they want trump he
calls msnbc msdnc that's straight out of
the trump playbook she claims that there
is voter fraud before
the election has actually been uh the
before the vote has been tallied before
elections uh
the results have been published that's a
classic trump thing of course trump
famously doing that in 2020 in the lead
up to the 2020 election for about six
months and then she claims that there is
a crime but she won't tell us what the
crime is and remember trump did that
with obama remember obama gate i don't
even remember at this point what obama
gate was even supposed to be because
trump never told us and when reporters
would say
there was one reporter in the press
briefing room who said what is obama
gate
and trump angrily said you know what it
is but he never actually told us just
insisting it was the biggest crime of
the century or something like that so
apparently it's not just democrats who
steal elections it's also
other republicans in primaries i guess
it's non-trump republicans now as of
this moment
carrie lake is leading but has not won
her primary i would love it
if carrie lake lost her primary hold on
a second we're not even able to see this
accurate there we go kerry lake current
with 80 percent reporting
carrie lake at 46 percent
and the second place candidate karen
taylor robson at 44 and remember this is
the republican primary merely to
determine who in november will face
katie hobbs katie hobbs easily winning
the democratic primary one thing uh that
you will notice is that um more people
voted in the republican primary than the
democratic there in arizona and we will
see what that
suggests might happen in november but at
least for now it would be an absolute
delight if carrie lake ends up losing
she is ahead by about 12 about 11 000
and a half votes right now with one out
of five votes still to be counted but
there's already voter fraud now if she
wins what will she say about voter fraud
will she say there was none of course
not
if she wins she will say there was voter
fraud
just not enough
to steal the election from me
that's the deal and we'll have that clip
of kerry lake speaking to von hilliard
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show